Let's see next game against Casanova,
maybe I'll get
Slavic exchanged again after the two
wins,
okay, well, then we'll play
Catalan or tarasch,
you just can't prevent that from
happening with white,
okay, it's unusual to beat it so early
So now you have
reached a position from the main variant in white, but with
more speed because the H6 is missing in
black and it is actually useful,
for example, it is not possible in
the main variant,
so now E4 threatens quite severely, I thought
four each threatens  not or what it is or
E4 knight E4
well that actually looks good too,
like
B6 can play easily
and now it's not that stupid
and then I have now then I do
n't have a particularly great move
yes that was stupid ne Somalia all sorts of
things  also against, for example,
bishop F6 bishop F6 knight D5 ne was
of course also possible
so that the six of us are standing
around in the area a bit stupidly
okay,
so
my idea is now to play queen B3 on the four
and then use the diagonal here,
which has yes  still a bit of problems
here too so he can't just
play E5 and so
wow
that's going well now knight D5 what's next
a knight deduction or
I don't really understand it yet
but I still have
knight simply F6  with chess,
okay, yes, but now it looks like it's
completely tied up or yes,
okay, of course the position was also difficult,
but now it's exploding extremely quickly.
I think the four patterns
on E4 are already making it really clear,
I guess